[Music]
go to john in tulsa oklahoma hey john
what's going on
hey guys how you doing today outstanding
brother what's what's up
all right well actually my coalition
kind of ties into the last college thing
um pretty much my wife and i got married
about two years ago um when we got
married we started baby steps did all
that made it through we're up on four
five and six now going through that
congratulations man
thank you very much um the problem that
i've run into now is i want to get we
never did a honeymoon or anything like
that so i want to take her somewhere as
a surprise
how do i do that
since we have combining combined bank
accounts and everything else where i can
withdraw the money to surprise her
without doing on a credit card or
something like that
oh good good question what what kind of
gift are we talking here i mean you have
to tell me the gift let's go listening
yeah well it's on a trip it's so it's
gonna be airfare and everything else
something i can't do cash for i got
people this is our debit card to
purchase the airline tickets and stuff
like that so
sure so what kind of budget do you have
for this whole gift all in
the whole gift is probably by the time
we do meals and everything excursions
over there and everything else probably
about two thousand to twenty five
hundred this is a serious gift man
yep well not we didn't do a honeymoon or
anything else so this is one of them
excursions big trees because we don't
treat ourselves so here it is so have
you guys agreed on what we think would
be appropriate for a birthday gift as
far as spending goes like is this in the
budget and she knows
yeah it's in the budget we've talked
about something similar to this and
everything else and i it was
just gonna jump and do it but i don't
know how to do it to do it as a surprise
aspect seeing that we share the accounts
yeah you know i'll share that one
account well there's there's a lot of
ways to go about that to where you're
not just using the debit card on that
website to purchase the flight i mean
you can do prepaid debit cards um and
things of that nature to where you could
basically debit that money out buy a
prepaid debit card with it and use that
debit card to then make all the
purchases for this gift that would be
the easiest one i had i've done a couple
of these john and i had i've got a buddy
my buddy todd will have bought some nice
things even when i buy christmas
presents i would send them to his house
um so that my wife and kids wouldn't
have but for a physical gift like that i
had a buddy that would
you know make the concert tickets
purchase that i wanted to surprise my
wife with and just exchange it back for
that very reason there so there were
some ways around that i would be careful
about opening a secret account or
something because again yeah that's what
i didn't want to do we're very open very
honest with everything and have it all
laid out there and
we'll sit down and go through the you
know statement at the end of the month
and make sure everything's budgeted out
and appropriate yeah i want to make sure
but a good surprise is so great man it's
so awesome could you also just say hey
i'm trying to do this big surprise don't
look do not log in
i wouldn't do that
just for a week because you if you if
you whitney came to you and did that you
would look immediately a hundred percent
that's exactly looking under the
christmas tree exactly yeah but like
john said it's a and this is a trip
right so you gotta book a few things
there's some flights hotels things like
that
correct yep yeah you could use a prepaid
debit card to do something like all of
that uh with no issue so you shouldn't
run into any problems if you do that now
you'd be getting an expensive card so
make sure that you can get one that has
no to low fees um that's not hey we're
gonna take a percentage of the amount
but if it's hey five bucks you're gonna
prepay to get this debit card that has
two thousand dollars on it then you're
good to go and you can use that and she
knows the money's coming out she goes
all right there's two grand that came
out what the heck is that and you go hey
it's a surprise i don't want the amount
to surprise don't worry about it that's
what i don't want her to go well hold on
you spent two grand on what now yeah
that part you can't really achieve
do what bob
sorry about that what
so you're are you wanting to hide the
amount from her too
she knows the amount but i figure if i
did the amount it's going to be kind of
obvious what's going on of course of
course so yeah get get with a friend get
a prepaid card um the thing i would stay
away from is opening up a secret account
somewhere at a secret bank and siphoning
money off and
um that just feels like a step in in the
wrong direction there yeah but i do love
the idea of a good surprise that's fun
man i'm pumped for that